sans transition du pas son reportage de
fin de notre journal d'aujourd'hui il
s'agit d'un anniversaire
astérix et obélix ont tous les deux 25
ans au même titre que tintin le belge
ils sont entrés dans l'histoire comme
les représentants d'une certaine
mentalité française
le reportage d'emmanuel veine puissance
de l'image et de la bande dessinée
on ne peut plus aujourd'hui évoquer nos
ancêtres les gaulois sans avoir recours
aux baies league c'est astérix
même les savants archéologues ont été
obligés d'en passer par là pour
l'inauguration du village gaulois qu'ils
ont reconstitué au jardin
d'acclimatation avec la complicité du
des réseaux le créateur des célèbres
personnages étonné de voir apparaître
des choses que nous avons créée pour
être tout petit oui fera tout petit sur
du papier l'histoire c'est un peu la
même chose on étudie dans les libres de
façon abstraite
d'où cette idée de la faire revivre en
grandeur nature uderzo a fait le tour du
propriétaire sous l'oeil fatigué d'un
espion romain d'outiller de façon
parfaitement exact les huttes avec les
objets de la vie quotidienne des
échoppes des artisans avec les outils
d'époque
on a aussi un peu inventé puisqu'on a pu
déguster la fameuse potion magique du
druide panoramix elle est bonne la
potion magique
j'aimerais bien trop loi du moins bien
il n'y a rien d'acquis eto'o
l'exposition durera deux ans on pourra y
vivre des journées à la gauloise manger
gaulois fini l'austérité des étudiants
et aux logiques on apprendra en se
distrayant démarrer un enfant avec un
éclat de rire c'est quelque chose de
fondamental c'est comme ça ensuite
l'image et aimer apprendre si voulant
petite île et dès le départ il ira pas
loin
comme toutes les aventures d'astérix et
obélix
l'inauguration s'est terminée par un
grand banquet il n'y avait pas de
sanglier grillé mais la cervoise a coulé
à flots oui cela se passe donc au jardin
d' acclimatation à paris